i can't count pi it's an irrational
number but i can embrace the spirit of
your proposal
and calculate the matrix coefficients
necessary for a unified field theory
do that get it
before fundamental forces the most
difficult to unify is
gravity because oh thank god
[Music]
yep right up
step right up for your chance
to meet the egyptian
god of knowledge he
has all the answers
no question too big
or small hello young man
do you have a question you'd like to
pose
i do but nobody in the history of
science has ever been able to answer it
well they haven't asked the great
god
right this way
[Music]
ask your question do you really possess
all knowledge you only get one question
kid
you want that to be it oh no
how can i unify the four fundamental
forces of the universe
now we're talking in order to unify
gravity
you must first understand that it is a
distortion of space time
wow even tucks in asleep
why am i not surprised
oh my oh you died you're a ghost now
look who's awake how are you feeling
i had a dream i solved a unified field
theory
well good for you but i can't remember
it
hmm you know you were mumbling something
about
gravity and forces you need to be more
specific
shelly you weren't making much sense
mother
a unified field theory is the holy grail
of physics
solving it would be the greatest
breakthrough in the history of science
and you forgot it that's funny
hello dr bowers it's sheldon cooper i
need you to administer more anesthesia
to me
no i don't have a dental problem i need
to re-enter a trance-like state so i can
communicate with thoth the god of
knowledge
i would argue that the greatest
discovery of physics is worth losing
your dental license
well it's not my fault you let them
publish your home phone number
if i was going to recapture my insight
into a unified field theory
i needed to find a way to put myself
back into an altered state of
consciousness
native americans would sit in sweat
lodges for hours to achieve this
i lasted a minute and a half
self-hypnosis is another means of
bringing stillness to the mind
when it isn't giving you a heart attack
the whirling dervishes of central asia
employ a repetitive spinning technique
to achieve a trance-like stage
[Music]
you